-Our first guest is a
six-time Oscar nominee,
starring in the new film
"Dear Evan Hansen,"
which opens in theaters
Friday, September 24th.
Here is Amy Adams!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Ah! I love you! Hi, Amy!
-Hi. It's good to see you.
-You look great.
Welcome back, welcome back.
Thank you for being here.
-Thank you for having me.
I wish I was there in person.
I miss you guys.
-I know. Yeah, I know.
We miss you, too.
I miss seeing your daughter,
as well.
-Yeah, she was really bummed
we weren't going to be there
in person.
She loves to go backstage
and eat all the treats.
So she was really --
I mean, she loves you.
-Yeah, of course, she doesn't
care about me at all, yeah.
-No, she doesn't.
-She just wants the treats.
-She just wants
that Tonight Dough.
Ever since you guys
gave her that, that's it.
-Our ice cream,
the Tonight Dough,
which is the greatest.
Do we have any?
Usually, we have a fake pint.
Here's a fake one now.
That's our --
She loves Tonight Dough?
This is it.
-It is so good.
-This is the best.
-It is the best. The best.
-How old is she now?
-She's 11.
-No.
-She is 11, yeah.
-That's wild.
-Yeah, 11 going on like 45.
So, I'm sure I'm gonna
get in trouble
for saying that, actually.
-Really?
-Well, she's at that age
where everything I do
embarrasses her,
which is fun for me.
I'm sure
it's very painful for her,
but it's fun for me.
-That's wild.
I've known her
her whole life then, huh?
-You have, yeah.
-That's wild, that's amazing.
Well, please tell her
I said hello,
or I can just say hi
if she's watching.
-I will.
-Yeah, please.
I'm going to send her
a case of this, by the way,
so she gets it --
-Oh, my gosh.
Yeah, I'm doing that because,
yeah, tell her I love her.
You had a very exciting summer
because you filmed
the sequel to "Enchanted,"
and I knew that.
You told me that you
were going to do.
[ Cheers and applause ]
The first one was giant,
and everyone is back for this.
What can you tell me
about the sequel?
-It was a lot of fun to film.
We filmed it in Ireland.
There is -- Everyone is back.
We also have
great additions to the cast.
We have Maya Rudolph.
-Yes!
-Some other great people. Yeah.
-Maya!
How is Maya! She's the best.
-Oh, she's amazing.
-She's so fun, right?
-She is so great in it.
She plays the baddie,
so we get to have
a lot of fun together.
There's a lot more singing
and a lot more dancing.
-Yeah, great.
-Which was humbling. Yeah.
-Humbling, for you?
-Well, yeah.
The last time I really danced
as much as I'm required
to dance in this,
I was in my 20s,
and now I'm not in my 20s.
And it feels different
in your 40s.
-It really does, yeah.
-Oh, yeah.
In my heart, I look like I'm
in my 20s when I'm dancing,
and then I would watch playback
and be like, "Whoa,
that's not the same."
[ Laughter ]
-You can do everything.
It is Broadway week
here on our show,
and I know you love Broadway.
I mean, how happy are you
that Broadway is back?
This is a giant thing.
-It's amazing.
I start talking really fast
when I talk about Broadway,
because I totally turn into
that high school student who
their whole life is musicals.
If you want to feel good
about things in the world,
just watch the casts returning,
because it's
the most joyful thing.
I've been on a deep dive of
watching everybody
celebrate the return,
and it's so uplifting.
And I'm so excited.
And I saw Ben last night
on the show.
He was brilliant.
I could keep going.
I start getting real fast-talky.
-I like when you get chatty.
It's fun 'cause we have
a rehearsal here,
and everyone is trying
to not get choked up
of how much we missed
these talented people
for almost two years.
It's like, "Gosh!"
And, man, oh, man, support.
Please go get tickets
to any Broadway show
you can possibly see.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's just the greatest.
But you're about to
make your debut
in the West End in London
at "The Glass Menagerie."
-I am, yes.
This is exciting.
-It's really exciting.
I think, you know,
during this time
where we didn't have
live theater,
I really realized
how much I missed it,
not juice being
an audience member
but that exchange of energy
that happens in theater,
live audiences
like you have there,
that's just so unique,
and it's just
something
I want to be a part of.
-Yeah, you got a little "Whoo!"
from someone.
-Whoo!
-We have a full audience here.
Yeah. There's nothing like it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Miss it.
-Do you rehearse now,
or how does it go into it
schedulewise?
How do you do it?
-Yeah, yeah.
We will rehearse,
and we open in may.
-Wow.
-Yeah, I'm nervous.
I have so much respect
for the craft of stage acting
and musicals and
the eight shows a week,
and I just look forward
to the challenge.
-I want to talk about
your new movie,
"Dear Evan Hansen"
when we come back.
More with Amy Adams
when we come back!